- My name's Daniel Botsman.
I teach in the history
department here at Yale,
and it's a great pleasure to
be able to welcome you all
today to Yale's 23rd
annual John W. Hall lecture
in Japanese studies.
As explained in these pamphlets
that hopefully you've all received.
The series, the whole series
was established in 1999
with the generous
support of Mrs Robin Hall
to honor the memory of
her husband, John W. Hall,
who was of course one of
the most important figures
in the development of Japanese studies
in the decades following World War II.
Professor Hall was a historian
primarily of pre-modern Japan,
who completed his PhD dissertation
at Harvard writing about Tanuma Okitsugu,
one of the important political figures
of the 18th century in Japan.
And he wrote the dissertation
under the direction of Edwin Reischauer.
He then began his scholarly
career at the University
of Michigan in 1949 before
moving to Yale in 1961
as the A. Whitney Griswald
professor of history.
As a scholar, he played a
critical role in opening the study
of pre-modern Japanese history
to the English speaking world
with a slew of important works,
including most importantly
perhaps his 1966 monograph,
government and local power
in Japan, 500 to 1700.
He also, of course, edited
the original Cambridge history
of Japan volumes and enduring
contribution to the field,
which is only now in the
process of being updated.
For all of his deep
engagement with the past,
he was also very much
an institution builder,
strongly committed to
the work of facilitating
the scholarship of the future.
At Yale, he was chair of
the history department
and of the Council on
East Station studies.
He was also master as it was
then known of Morse College,
and he trained a generation
of graduate students here
who went on to reshape the field,
including figures such as Harper Litho,
Jeffrey Mass, James
McClain, and Suzanne Gay.
Outside of Yale,
he played a central role in
building the institutional
structures that have
supported the study of Japan
and Asia more generally ever since,
including the Association for
Asian Studies, for example.
Each year then with the exception
I will say of 2020, 21',
we took a little COVID break.
Yale's current faculty have
the privilege of extending
to an eminent scholar of Japan,
an invitation to deliver
the whole lecture.
And we're extremely fortunate
this year to have been able
to convince Professor Richard
J. Samuels Ford International
Professor of Political Science
at the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
to travel to the wilds
of New Haven to speak
to us all today.
I can honestly think of no
active scholar in any discipline,
better qualified to deliver
the whole lecture in Japanese studies.
He is a towering figure,
and I don't mean just because
he's actually like me,
quite tall, and a former
basketball player,
although that is also true.
Professor Samuels was born
in Brooklyn and grew up
just across the sound in
Long Island, on Long Island.
While in high school
he met his wife Debra,
who we're also extremely pleased
to be able to welcome to New Haven.
Hi, welcome Debra.
(audience applause)
If you're not already familiar with them,
I would recommend Debra Samuel's,
Japanese and Korean cookbooks,
which I think are among
the very best available
to introduce those cuisines
to people in English.
And I hope you won't mind me saying that.
As college students,
they went to Japan together
for the first time to Kyushu,
which is a place that
I know some people here
have a special connection to also.
And then after that initial
experience, professor Samuels
went on to complete an MA at Tufts
and then his PhD at MIT where he has,
of course gone on to build
an illustrious career.
Like John W. Hall, Professor
Samuels is very much
an institution builder who has held
many significant leadership roles,
not only at MIT, where he has served
in many important roles,
including as the director
of the Center for International Studies,
but also in numerous
organizations responsible
for stewarding different
aspects of US Japan relations
in particular, including the
Japan US Friendship Commission,
the Japan Committee of the
National Research Council,
and the US Japan Conference
on Cultural and Educational Interchange.
The contributions are, of course,
these contributions are of
course more than matched
by his achievements as a scholar.
In the age of Wikipedia
and indeed ChatGPT,
there is I think no need for me to list
all of Professor Samuel's
important publications.
I suspect ChatGPT might
add a few creative ones.
But given the occasion,
it would be remiss of me not
to mention that his 1994 book,
Rich Nation Strong Army National Security
and the Technological
Transformation of Japan
was recipient of the John W. Hall Prize
from the Association of Asian Studies
for best book in the
field of Japanese studies
among other distinguished prizes.
More generally, let me say that in an era
in which all disciplines seem to battle
with the curse of over specialization,
professor Samuel's corpus
of scholarly work speaks
not just across subfields
but across disciplines.
I certainly think it's true
that there's no Japan political
scientist whose work is
assigned in history classes
as often as those of Professor Samuels.
And part of the reason
for that is simply that
he always takes on topics of
clear and obvious importance.
Think for example, of his books on 311
or on Japanese brand strategy.
For all of the seriousness
with which Professor Samuels engages
the specificities of Japan's
political culture moreover,
he's equally someone who thinks
broadly and comparatively
as perhaps most obviously evidenced
by his pathbreaking comparative
study of political leaders
in Japan and Italy,
Machiavelli's children.
Professor Samuels is also a
wordsmith of unusual skill
and talent whose books
are replete with sentences
that make you smile as well as think,
and which are full of
smaller treasures of wisdom,
as well as compelling
answers to large questions.
Finally, let me say that
Professor Samuel's work
is characterized not only by
a refusal to pull punches,
but also by a level of
honesty and integrity,
which commands respect even
from those who might disagree
or take very different stances
on key political questions.
His most recent book, Special Duty,
a History of the Japanese
Intelligence community
provides an excellent example of this.
I'm sure I'm not the only
person who's been forced
to rethink their own
preconceptions about issues such as
the controversial 2013
designated states secret.
Sorry, I knew I was gonna stumble on this.
Designated state's secret law
as a result of reading
that wonderful book.
I've gone on much too long, I know,
but I hope some of what I've
said will help you understand
why I am really excited to
hear Professor Samuel's lecture
today, and I hope without
that you will now join with me
in welcoming him to the podium.
(audience applause)
- Thanks very much, Danny.
It's a pleasure to be here and it's,
it's an honor really to
address you this afternoon,
not least because
the lecture series pays
tribute to one of the nation's
and Yale's most distinguished
Japan specialist,
John Whitney Hall.
Now, I'll be speaking
about Japan's response
to its security
environment this afternoon,
and it's a topic I suspect
that Professor Hall would've
found of interest in a
different security environment,
but would certainly a found of interest.
But before I go there,
I want to reflect a bit on
what brought me to this topic
and to connect the journey to
my mentor Lucian, Lucian Pie.
Steve, you were,
Lucian was still around when
you were right. Okay, good.
You'll enjoy this I hope.
He earned his PhD here at Yale,
so it's not entirely inappropriate.
But for Lucian's Festschrift
my co-editor was Myron Wiener,
and I asked each of our authors to,
they were all comparativist
of one stripe or another to,
we asked them to reflect
on the political culture
of foreign area studies.
Why do comparativist some comparativist
pick certain topics and not others,
and what's the political
culture that what are they,
what are they, what are they bathing in?
Our presumption was that
Lucian would be very,
would've been very comfortable with that,
namely that there are academic
norms and academic values
that stimulate and perhaps legitimate
some inquiry and preclude others.
And that was, Lucian was
very comfortable with that.
It turned out a very easy case to make.
It was quite clear that the circumstances
of foreign politics,
that they shape our research agendas,
that was, that was, that was
not a hard thing to discover.
One obvious example from the
Festschrift session was made
by one of his former, Lucian's
former students who was
a specialist on Soviet
politics and who explained to
an understanding audience
that some of the best,
that the Soviet politics
contributed very little
to the literature and
political participation. Duh.
But another was that some
of the best conceptual work
on social movements and ethnicity came
from the study of South Asia.
Again, this all made perfect sense.
But as I dug into the Japanese case,
it was less obvious why
with the notable exception
of Chalmers Johnson and maybe Ronald Dor,
Japanese contributed
so little to political,
economic or social theory.
Why were we, I wondered theory
takers and not theory makers.
Why didn't we do what
specialists and other fields
of comparative inquiry did?
Was it something about
us as Japan scholars
or was it something about Japan?
And it was a few short
steps from those questions
that led to a larger one.
Had we somehow been captured?
Were we had captured intelligentsia?
And if so, who was our captor?
Were we slaves to convention
or perhaps to politics?
And if it's the latter, did
we serve our own sovereign?
It was politics that was driving us.
And this is something that John Dower,
another great Japan specialist
and a colleague of mine at MIT.
He once charged that, or
is it because they were,
we were captives to a foreign sovereign
as the so-called Japan bashers
of the 80s and 90s suggested?
Did the considerable resources
of that were made available
to Japan specialists by Japanese sources
dampen our enthusiasm to say
critical things about Japan?
Did the resources that were
made available to us by
the US government dampen our enthusiasm
to criticize the United States?
In short, I found it with no
that with no small regret,
that for decades on both
sides of the Pacific,
of the Pacific War,
the political culture of
Japanese political studies
in the United States had
corresponded much more directly
to the ebbs and flows
of bilateral relations
with Japan and the, between
Japan and the United States,
than to the unfettered
intellectual curiosity
of those of us who were studying
and our predecessors who
were studying the topic.
That is Japanese political
studies had lurched from one
to another intellectual fashion,
and we likely missed a lot in the process.
I know I did.
I missed a lot and I'll get
to that point immediately.
But so let me indulge in sort of an,
a personal account because
it wasn't until 30 years
after Lucian's Festschrift was published.
It was two decades
after I wrote Rich Nation Strong Army
that Danny referred to.
And at least seven to eight
years after securing Japan,
the book on Japan's
grand strategy came out
that I realized that I had written two,
two books about Japanese
national security without
interrogating two of the
most important topics
of that domain.
Completely ignored how
Japan does intelligence.
And I completely ignored
in those two studies,
the prospects for Japan's nuclear breakout
and acquisition of nuclear weapons.
And indeed in the business
of the Japanese state,
an earlier book that was not
on national security per se.
It had a very fact chapter on
nuclear power in the history
of the nuclear power industry
in Japan without ever once
my exploring what Japan was planning
to do with all that plutonium,
that it was producing or
why it needed have the,
basically the a full
cycle nuclear capability.
So about a decade ago when
it hit me that I had missed
all that stuff, I began
to wonder why I had failed
to address those topics and why
no one pointed it out to me.
And I noticed that virtually
no one else had tackled
those issues either,
which is consistent with the point
I was starting with here with you.
So I've spent the last decade trying
to backfill both topics.
And that brings me back to Lucian Pie.
I wrote a piece recently for
a really interesting volume
that was edited by Connie Ryer
and Nora Cottman in Germany.
And as I told a group at Columbia earlier,
well late last year, that
and Charlie knows this well,
he was there.
When passing graduate
students in the hallway,
Lucian used to stop the students
and ask invariably, are
you being brave scholar?
Are you being brave?
And we would all nonplus not
know exactly how to respond
to such a question.
It seemed bizarre to us at the time.
And we all smiled and we walked on.
But I have never forgotten the question.
And I realize now that he wasn't joking.
You need to be brave because brave
and now certainly brave means many things,
but it appears as a choice
in one form or another
at nearly every stage of
a major project in our,
in what we do as academics.
Starting with our choice
of dissertation topics.
But it's easier to hue seems to me,
to disciplinary norms
and to take on subjects
that have already been
validated by our mentors and to,
and our peers than it is to
get out ahead of the subfield
or even the discipline.
And that was, that's been
especially the problem
in Japanese studies, it seems to me.
But in the current issue
of the Texas National Security Review,
a former colleague of
ours at MIT, Frank Gavin,
speaks directly to this issue
and I want to just quote him.
"The public minded scholar is obliged
"to disturb the status quo.
"She should complicate stylized narrative,
"undermine the conventional wisdom,
"make people uncomfortable,
and most of all,
"force them to challenge the
assumptions and to think."
And we all know how to review
an existing literature.
We know how to identify a narrow niche
in which to drill down
for new information.
We spend a lot of time in
graduate school learning
how to search for and apply
other people's models.
We answer other people's questions,
but it's much more difficult
and much more risky
to formulate new questions
and explore the previously
unexplored in new ways.
And we often fail, and I
have often failed to do that.
Solutions, brave scholars
attempt to hack through
the undergrowth of difficult
problems with new tools
and especially with new
questions, important questions.
This is difficult and it's also risky.
And as Gavin points out,
also very unpopular.
You don't get to go to the
garden parties quite as often.
And the risks are greater
when the problem's tougher
or when the conventional wisdom is thicker
because taking risks
involves breaking China.
It's a small city, breaking China.
I'm not here to warmonger.
But this is,
this is because there were
rules and norms in every field.
Again, this is back to that Festschrift.
And not least of all in Japanese studies
where rule number one is
decorum, polite, be polite.
Observing decorum may not be difficult,
but it does constrain
creativity it seems to me.
In my own case,
this challenge was most clearly manifest
when I asked my Todi Unche,
my professor at Tokyo University
for an affiliation with
his new research center.
I was doing rich nations,
what turned into rich nation, strong army.
And I wanted to go where the
cutting edge of work was being
done in Japan, and it was in
his center and he declined.
He said, no, you can't affiliate
with us because he said,
my topic was,
and something he had organized
an important study group
on which I knew of.
He said it was too sensitive
and, (speaking Japanese)
the guys upstairs meaning the bureaucracy
wouldn't be comfortable with it.
And then after situating myself elsewhere,
I asked for a copy of
the group's report and I,
he didn't provide it.
Since I had followed all the decarus rules
of Japanese studies. (speaking Japanese)
The gift exchanges and the
more substantive accommodations
over many years.
And since he was supposed
to be an academic,
I thought we were in the same business.
I was shocked.
In the event I wrote the
book I wanted to write,
and it won several prizes,
as Danny kindly said,
including the John Whitney
Hall prize, which was lovely.
But I found myself excluded
from a range of activities,
a range of activities
for at least a decade.
And so Lucian pies in
junction to be brave,
which I never saw myself
as understanding before,
stayed in my head.
And it's still there.
There are still a lot of
questions we have not thought
to ask for a variety of reasons,
some of which I've tried to outline here
in my introductory remarks.
But it's, this is even more important.
It seems to me when, as in
political science methods
are getting more,
at least I can speak to
political science methods
are getting more attention
than substance in some cases.
So let's turn to substance if we can.
Actually, what was on the poster is,
is the substance that
I want to talk about.
I think that students of
national security who were born
after the Asia Pacific War
find it particularly difficult
to suspend disbelief about the
prospects for war and peace
in contemporary Asia,
particularly contemporary Japan.
And, that's what I'd like
to discuss this afternoon,
not least because the
views of Japan's leaders
in Japanese public opinion
have clearly shifted
in the last decade or two.
The way scholars of international
relations get at this
is to work par paradigmatically.
This is old stuff to
many of you, but it's,
it's just useful as a way in
which is to talk about the
paradigms very, very briefly.
So I apologize in advance
for oversimplifying,
but let me just suggest
that the constructivist,
the liberal and the realist
perspectives have each
had their day in Japan's
post-war journey to the present.
And by the present,
I'm referring to the most recent
announcement of Japan's new
national security strategy in
which was just in December,
and I'll just refer to
it going forward now
as the NSS, National Security Strategy.
So let me start by
flicking at each of these,
these three paradigms just
to frame the root Tokyo
has taken vis-a-vis the
alliance with the United States.
And I'll start with the
constructivist notion that to some
a post-war Japan has been pacifist
as a matter of national
identity after the war.
You know, you're familiar with
how article nine stipulates
that Japan will not maintain
land, sea or air forces,
and you are no doubt familiar
with how decades of so-called
anti militarists public opinion was shaped
by the ghosts of militarists
past. And this is not untrue.
This actually, this
constructivist notion does explain
a lot of that I think.
I sometimes refer to the
shroud of, (speaking Japanese).
You trying to get Japan away
from militarists, militarists past.
And pacifism, of course,
was enshrined in law and declared
to be Japan's national
identity at least after 1945.
And anti militarists identity was invoked
to constrain any Japanese
military capabilities,
particularly offensive ones like missiles
and carriers and airborne
refueling and things like that.
The identity also included
so-called nuclear allergy,
which made it impossible to even imagine.
This is where I fell down,
where it made it impossible
to even imagine Japan
having thought about
in the acquisition of nuclear
power, nuclear weapons.
But it did. We now know that.
And they talk about it openly now.
But this identity also included, as I say,
the nuclear allergy,
a ban on arms exports,
an undersized intelligence capability,
and a prohibition on the
military use of space.
It seemed that as a result,
for five decades or so
after the Asia-Pacific War,
any serious discussion
of national security
was a dangerous third world, third rail
for an ambitious Japanese
political candidate.
Now, what I wanna do is
just shift over slightly
and connect it, this idea
into the liberal paradigm
so we can interrogate this
identity more closely.
As you know, Japanese conservatives
have governed Japan
virtually without a break
since the end of the US occupation.
It's well understood that
this conservative camp,
I should say it's less
well understood that
this conservative camp
was never monolithic.
And for most of the second
half of the 20th century,
Japan followed the preferences
of its greatest post-war
statesman, which was Joshi Daigaku.
The LDP was dominated by
his wing of the party,
which was a very pragmatic
wing of the LDP, the liberal.
He was not in the LDP.
He left politics before the LDP was formed
in November of 55', 1955.
But his school really
governed, for the most part,
for the next 20, 30 years.
The Yoshida doctrine, his
idea about national security
was brilliant politically.
It sustained the pragmatist
power and for the most part
kept military realists,
who I'll get to in a moment
at arm's length.
Japan constrained itself,
self-imposed constraints
and sheltered under US protection
and invoked its pacifist identity.
In doing so, it maneuvered
cleverly to avoid entanglement
in US wars, and there were many of those.
Now, it enabled Japan
to get back on its feet
without overextending itself
through defense, defense
spending. A conscious choice.
And it was a choice in,
from a liberal perspective of
interest groups fighting with
one another about what
will drive the engine
of post-war reconstruction.
Would it be defense?
Has the defense industry
wanted with Metis,
or would it be everything else,
which is what the finance ministry wanted?
It was everything else.
It made economic rehabilitation
Japan's priority.
Japan would remain lightly
armed and would avoid becoming
too involved with
international strategic affairs
while taking advantage
of US security guarantees
and getting rich from access
to robust US markets and technology.
Now, politically, the
greatest benefit was that
the Japanese public and
Japan's neighbors both
would be reassured that
Japan no longer posed
a threat to them, to the home, to the home
or to the neighbors.
In exchange, Japan would
provide the United States
forward basis, it still does.
So Japan's cheap writing
was in everyone's interests
and became a blueprint
for Japanese defense
and foreign policy efforts
for the next half century.
Seen in this, in this liberal view,
it was not built on a national identity,
rather on a political calculation.
This was about domestic politics.
And by the early 2000s
LDP pragmatists ran outta steam, it seems,
and the party's
nationalists gained momentum
in their long and very erratic march
to consolidating power and
controlling Japan's foreign
and security policies.
And moreover, by this time,
domestic squabbles within
the LDP had been overtaken
by marked shifts in Japan's
security environment,
a new world order was forming.
So given that it's a new world
order and balances of power
are changing, I mean, great
segue to the realist paradigm.
Even before the end of the Cold War,
Japan had begun to salami slice
away piece by piece slowly
the self-imposed constraints
of the Yoshida doctrine.
In the 1980s, they extended
the sea lines of communication,
out, defense of the sea
lanes of communication out
a thousand nautical miles.
That's not terribly distant,
but symbolically very important.
In the 1990s,
they sent mine sweepers
to the Persian Gulf after
the conflict ended.
But de facto they had
military use of space.
By the 2000S,
they were sending destroyers
to escort tankers,
to Diego Garcia to fuel
us and British war planes
to fight operation enduring
freedom in Afghanistan.
And the salami slicing simply accelerated.
It really ramped up in the
2010s and into this decade.
Collective self-defense became
possible reinterpretation
of the constitution to allow
Japan's military to protect
the American military
should have come under fire,
and under other kinds of conditions,
which we can talk about.
But they built a naval facility in Jabuti
for 10s of millions of dollars.
They loosened their arms export,
control ban self-imposed.
They created this new state
secrets law that Danny referred
to, that we all got exercised about
and realized that was not
such a terrible thing.
Again, I felt the same way
that he did as I got into it.
Stood up a cyber command. They
shifted to Southern defense.
They stood up a Marine
Corps, a Marine Corps.
That's an offensive capability
last time I checked.
And an open discussion
of a nuclear deterrent.
And I haven't even come
to the current NSS yet,
but I'm getting there.
I promise, I promise you I am.
By 2021, the shift in East
Asia's balance of power
had become very clear to most Japanese.
And with that, so had the
salience of national security
in domestic Japanese politics.
And that year, of 2021,
three of four candidates for
the presidency of the LDP
and therefore for the prime ministership
to succeed Sue Tsukasa.
Three of the four of them
to be prime minister,
emphasized defense issues
and said they were willing
to raise the defense budget.
I mean, this was hetero
docs beyond repair,
under earlier assumptions
about Japan's pacifist national identity.
And three of the four
said they would do that.
And the fourth one came in dead last.
Okay, so this emboldened,
it was a good reading
actually of the public,
of changes in public opinion as well.
Clearly, Japanese public
opinion on national security
had shifted in the direction of broader,
more realistic security discourse.
And, we should credit Abe
Shinzo, prime minister,
the late prime minister with part of that.
But of course, his government
that is Abe's government
as he was trying to
push the Japanese public
into a more realistic posture
and appreciation for Japan's having
a more realistic pasture,
had no little help from
two provocative neighbors,
North Korea and China, and
as well as from Washington.
And the help from Washington
is counterintuitive.
The help from Washington with,
came from what many Japanese came to,
to openly fear was that the United States
would simply not be as
committed to defending Japan
as it had been before China's rise,
and especially before North Korea acquired
intercontinental ballistic missiles.
It changed everything.
And so the confidence in
the United States declined,
especially with that first ICBM test
by the North Koreans in 2017.
And now by last year,
the majority of Japanese
polled on these issues
viewed China as a threat and reporting,
the reported feeling, and
this a quote from the survey.
"That US influence will weaken."
Now, that's realism 101 in a sense.
Japan is no longer driving
its security bus with one foot
on the brake. It's now become
a realist in realist clothing.
And this is a, this is a change.
And what I want to talk
about in the time I have left
are three realist oriented
questions that are core
to the US Japan Alliance and
to Japanese national security.
The first is how far Japan
would go to balance China.
The second is how far Japan
would go to defend Taiwan.
And the third is to what
extent is Japan hedging
against abandonment by the United States?
Now to answer these questions,
it helps to provide I think, more of a,
a feel for the contours of
Japan's security environment
as articulated in the NSS.
I told you I would get there, we're here.
The new NSS, which is the
first one in a decade,
has attracted a great deal of attention.
It's more blunt, it's more ambitious
and it's more muscular than
anything that preceded it.
And it's also occasionally
as opaque as all the,
as the many things that preceded it.
But by far the most
remarked upon innovation,
let's call it, military innovation,
is its authorization of
the new standoff missile
counterstrike capability.
In making the case for counterstrike,
which the NSS goes to
great pains to insist,
is not in violation of Article nine
of the Japanese constitution,
nor Japan's principle
of exclusively defensive defense.
It declares existing BMD,
ballistic missile defense
and missile capabilities simply
to be no longer sufficient
to deter its adversaries.
Its adversaries, means China, North Korea.
And it, and to deter aggression
says the, says the report.
Less clear though is which
missiles will be acquired.
It looks like it's tomahawks
and who will do the targeting
because Japan doesn't
have sophisticated missile
targeting capabilities yet.
So this is especially problematic
because it's, as I say,
it's C3I capabilities are
two underdeveloped for
the missiles to be credible as
an autonomous deterrent yet.
So that looks like the United
States then plays a role.
At least there are whispers
that the United States military
will play, help play a role in targeting.
And close behind the
counterstrike decision
in media, inc spilled the NSS
now formally commits Japan
to doubling its defense budget
as a percentage GDP over
the next five years.
Now, it's not clear though
how an underfunded government
of Japan's gonna pay for all this.
There's a lot, that's a lot of money.
And so the other thing to notice is not,
is that there's considerable opposition
inside the government, inside the LDP,
the ruling, the ruling party to new taxes.
This is, they don't wanna
raise taxes for this,
they don't wanna wanna raise taxes at all
'cause they wanna get
reelected and that's not,
that's not irrational.
But there's much speculation therefore,
that a lot of the spending,
the doubling of the GD,
percentage of GDP will
not be new spending.
So for example, there's this
wonderful prestidigitation
by which the Japan Coast Guard
and some government funded
dual use R&D budgets
are now gonna be swept
into the defense budget.
That takes care of a
whole hunk of the increase
in defense spending right there.
Japan's Coast Guard is
a non-trivial force.
And it's not clear how Japan
will spend whatever
funding is actually new,
like for the counter, the
counterstrike capability.
Now third, the centrality of the alliance
in the, in the NSF was reaffirmed
and really earlier than
the NSF was reaffirmed
by both countries, even
to the point of openly
considering the use of combined forces
in selected contingencies
in Northeast Asia.
Biden administration loved that.
They cheered when the NSS,
bluntly referred to China as the,
this is a quote from the
national security strategy.
"The greatest strategic
challenge to ensuring the peace
"and security of Japan and
the international community."
They pulled no punches.
And someone in Washington may
have gone hoarse cheering.
It's the statement in the
NSS that Japan must respond
to China's threats to the
rule-based international order
in cooperation with Washington
and "other like-minded countries."
We'll get to those other
like-minded countries in a moment.
But the, it also speaks
to the strategic use
of overseas development assistance, aid,
the strategic use of aid
openly in the document,
presumably in the form
of increased transfers
of military equipment
to naval vessels, for example,
in aircraft to align
states in Southeast Asia.
And finally, we can see
an interesting changes
in how Japan's signature cons,
interesting changes in
Japan's signature concept
of comprehensive security
is characterized.
Some of you in looking around the room,
not many of you will
remember that in the 1980s,
Japanese strategists
associated with Yoshida
and the Yoshida doctrine invented
the term comprehensive security
to justify low defense
spending because security
included economics and
trade and technology.
And therefore we shouldn't
spend so much money
on the military. Very interesting concept.
And, they'd emphasize Japan's
commitments to diplomacy
and foreign economic policy,
particularly energy policy.
But today's NSS speaks instead
to not comprehensive security,
but to comprehensive national power.
Not the same thing at all.
And fore grounds the military alongside
the intelligence community in the,
in Japan's national security toolkit.
Now, all this said, there was one large,
very large dog that didn't
bark in any of this.
And that's of course what I've referred
to several times as a nuclear breakout.
It didn't bark in the NSS, but it did bark
after the Ukraine war started.
Former prime minister Abe minced no words
within three days, maybe four of the,
the Russian aggression
into Ukraine invasion.
He called on the government
to discuss the viability
of nuclear sharing with the United States.
He said we should have that conversation.
But Prime Minister Kishida,
who by the way some of you
will know is from Hiroshima.
He passed on this and
it's his NSS after all.
Now, his strategy, it's
his government strategy,
his name is on it.
And it states clearly that
there will be no change
to Japan's three non-nuclear principles.
Japan is and this is a direct quote from
a really wonderful analysis by an Israeli,
an Israeli analyst.
He said, "Japan is the
most salient example
"in the world of nuclear
hedging among global powers."
And has already, as we know,
openly embraced the deterrent
benefits as they see it,
of nuclear latency.
That is the, the nuclear hedge. Okay.
In fact, a sitting
secretary of defense talked
about after 311 the need to
maintain nuclear power in order
to have, in order to have enough fuel
and weapons grade materials
for nuclear weapons
as a signal of latency.
And that was a,
that was as clear a
statement as you can get.
But the NSS disingenuously,
I thought declared its commitment
to arms controlled disarmament
and non-proliferation.
So it's in that nether world
of we could do this if we want
to do it, we can talk
about this in the Q&A.
But we could do this if we wanna do it.
We have the technology,
we have the equipment,
we have the material,
but we don't wanna do it.
Don't make us do it,
but don't play with us
because we could do it and so forth.
You get the idea.
So nuclear arm and even
if it's German style,
German style nuclear sharing
has been left for another day.
I don't think it's entirely,
I can't imagine that it's
entirely off the agenda
if my reading of Japanese
concern about American commitment
and capabilities is correct.
So from a realist perspective,
nowhere is the shift
of the regional balance
of power in China's favor,
potentially more consequential
for Japan than Taiwan.
To get to that second
issue I wanted to raise,
which sits along the first
island chain at a strategic
choke point for naval forces
in the Western Pacific
and is critical to securing
Japan's southern flag.
Tokyo, very long cautious
in offering overt support to Taiwan,
issued a defense white paper in 2021,
declaring that Japan will,
"Pay close attention to
the Taiwan's situation
"with a sense of crisis."
And that was followed by
a series of 2021, 2022
trial balloons that were sent
up by senior Japanese defense
officials who proclaimed that
Japan has to defend Taiwan,
will have to defend Taiwan.
I could give you the quotes, but for the,
I won't go into them. They're
all basically that message.
So it wasn't a huge surprise
that the NSS went bold on this.
Although it declares this no change
to the 1972 Japan China communique
or to its relationship with Taiwan.
The NSS stresses that Japan
and Taiwan "Share values,"
and labels Taiwan,
"An extremely important
partner and dear friend."
Now these developments are striking,
but given that Japan
has no treaty obligation
to defend Taiwan,
and given the economic stakes embedded
in the China relationship,
which are considerable.
China is Japan's largest
single trading partner.
I'd guess that some Japanese
prime ministers like Yoshida
would hesitate ordering
the SDF to fight in support
of US forces in the
Taiwan contingency until,
or unless there are there
the Japanese civilians or
soldiers fall to hostile fire.
So we'll watch the space
and remind ourselves
that just a few years ago,
even a general discussion
of these shifts and plans
would've ensured a government
crumbling thunder clap.
This time, crickets, crickets.
Now this is possible for
two not unrelated reasons.
First, because the US foreign
policy has been feeding
an abandonment discourse.
There's no other way to describe it.
There's an abandonment
discourse in Japan now
for several years.
And second, because the center
of gravity of Japanese public
opinion has shifted to the right.
To test this, very crudely,
I'm not known as a methodologist,
but to test this very crudely,
I took a quick look at how
the ragged US withdrawal
from Afghanistan in August
of 2021 was connecting
to the Japanese conversation about Taiwan
and about a Taiwan contingency.
And I found hundreds of thousands of links
in a Japanese Google search
to stories, links to stories,
asking questions like, will
Taiwan be like Afghanistan?
Will Japan also be abandoned
by the United States?
The American withdrawal
from Afghanistan galvanized
attention in Japan.
And predictably, very predictably,
the crisis in Ukraine,
further stimulated these concerns.
So what was a low boil of
concern about American commitment
and capabilities and really
happy talk among alliances
at formal meetings like
two plus twos and so forth.
What was a low boil began to
bubble really quite vigorously.
And so when I did the same Google search,
but subs after the Ukraine crisis began.
Google returned twice the
number of hits that it did on
the Afghanistan question.
And sifting through hundreds of them,
it was clear to me that
many Japanese were fretting
about whether failed US support
for Ukraine might undermine
extended deterrence in Northeast Asia.
So let's take a look at this concern
and take on that third question
that I mentioned, which is,
what is Japan doing about it,
about this by hedging, Japanese hedging?
It's a classic realist question.
But the blunt version,
blunt version is that
while Japanese leaders
know that the US alliance
is their best bet, there's
no question about that.
Tokyo has been nonetheless
actively hedging for some time
and is doing so more actively these days
with very broad public support,
and ironically with US encouragement.
Very interesting,.
The Russian invasion of
Ukraine made it very easy
for Japan's hedging inclined realists.
Just months ago,
the chief of the ground
self-defense forces, well,
the former chief of the
ground self-defense forces,
the army, the Japanese army,
made a very succinct
case for the connection
between the Ukraine war
and further discussions
of a nuclear weapons option.
Was a former chief of
the Japanese military.
He said, "The world learned from Ukraine
"that the United States will
not intervene militarily
"in the event of a possible nuclear war."
That we were deterred from
getting in by Russia's possession
and Putin's, you know, Putin's behavior,
declarations and capabilities.
So besides its agreements with Washington,
Japan now has two plus twos,
that's defense and state,
defense and foreign ministers
meeting together bilaterally
with five countries.
It has acquisition and
cross servicing agreements,
the axes with four Gsomias,
which are intelligence sharing agreements
with seven countries,
bilateral military training
with eight different countries
and has ink defense
equipment transfer agreements
with five different countries.
And in recent years,
there's been a noticeable
increase in the exercises
and port visits to Japan by countries
that are not the United States of America.
From Japan's perspective,
this is designed to keep
major states onside,
and neighbors onside vis-a-vis China
and to hedge against
what the MOD think tank.
The MOD think tank, meaning NIDS,
the National Institute
for Defense Studies.
Openly has identified as the, like,
"Likely shrinking of US relative power
"in a multi-polar order."
Now, some initiatives are more robust
or more modest I should say, than others,
but there have been developments
of note that have preceded
in parallel with a tightened
hug of the United States.
So I'm gonna just quickly flick at them
and then I'll get out of your way.
But the one that has
attracted the most attention
is the quad, known as
the quad, which comprises
the United States,
Australia, Japan and India,
four countries the chair
concerns about and seek
to counter China's assertive
behavior in the Indo-Pacific.
It's a vast area, of course,
through which the world's
exports in more than a third
of its global imports are transit.
Now, this is not a NATO by any,
it's not a mini NATO,
mini me by any any extent.
But quad leaders do
hold regularly scheduled
strategic consultations and
joint military exercises.
It's the beginning of
something bigger it seems.
Anyway, there are important
bilateral initiatives as well.
Last year, Tokyo and Canberra signed
a reciprocal access agreement
to establish the two
countries defense forces
to cooperate with each
other for the first time,
enhanced partnerships
with European states,
including the Brits who trained annually.
Now with the Japanese ground
self-defense force in Japan.
Last year, Tokyo and London signed
a reciprocal access agreement modeled
on the one with Australia.
And perhaps the biggest and
for US defense contractors,
the most unwelcome news was
the agreement signed late
last year by the UK, Italy, and Japan.
All three partners in the
Lockheed Martin F35 program
to form a new partnership of equals,
"To develop a sixth
generation fighter platform
"for the Japanese."
And for the first time,
a Japanese combat plane
will not be purchased,
co-developed or co-produced
with the United States.
Now for its part, France
with has 2 million nationals
and 8,000 military personnel
in the Indo-Pacific
has strengthened its ties
with Japan and even Germany,
which you wouldn't think
of as having anything
to defend necessarily out in the east,
in the South China Sea and so forth.
It has no Pacific
territories in the south down
in the Philippines Sea.
Anyway, it delighted many in
Japan by sending a frigate
to Northeast Asia and telling the press,
this is the thing that
really got people excited,
wasn't the frigate.
Frigate didn't impress many
people, certainly not China.
But that saying publicly
that China cannot be allowed
to impose their own order in
the region, it's the Germans.
And of course,
none of these relationships
compares to the US Japanese,
or even to the Australia
Japanese security ties.
But it's worth noting how
security stopped being
a third rail for aspiring Japanese leaders
as China's power grew
and as America's power
has declined relatively.
So let me end by returning
to the liberal paradigm
for a second and speak
to the divisions within the
Japanese strategic community
regarding national security.
Although his cabinet is
responsible for the new NSS,
as I've said,
prime Minister Kishida
is not a military realist
in the Abe mold.
Indeed we recall that
he became prime minister
over Abe's objections, opposition,
and therefore felt it necessary
as a matter of political logic.
He can count faction numbers
and felt it necessary as a
matter of political logic
to accept a harder line NSS
than he was usually associated
with after he was,
he was considered dovish
in the Yoshia pragmatic
in the Yoshida school.
This was a struggle for him.
For a time he and his supporters
took pains to remind voters
that China was Japan's
largest trading partner.
And right after taking
office in late 2021,
Mr. Kishida declared his
government would make an effort
to stabilize relations with Beijing.
Immediately stepping into office,
he sees the opportunity to insert
a more China moderate party chief
and a more China moderate
foreign minister,
who actually had chaired
the China Japan Friendship,
Parliamentary friendship
Committee for four years.
That got some, that
got people's attention.
So it was a reminder in
a way, but he still went,
went along with a hard line NSS.
So this is a reminder
that a range of visions
among Japanese strategists
persists even within the LEP.
Now, the military,
the military realism that
seems to have prevailed
in the production of the new NSS remains
one of only four grand strategic choices.
And some of you have will have heard me.
I hope or I have read that
I've written about this
in the past.
I'll, this is very briefly flick.
But these realists are the folks who,
that the realists are the folks who know
they can't balance China alone.
And while claiming to be all
in with the United States
have been busy developing,
busy diversifying Japan's
dependence on Washington,
but they're also band wagoners,
bandwagons with China in Japan,
mostly in the business
community who would prefer
that Japan accommodate the Chinese power.
And they see China as
the new global leader,
and US' time has passed.
And their numbers has
have dwindled as China
has overplayed its hand,
frankly, in the region.
But their view is not irrelevant.
Just last fall, the vice chair of Japan's,
one of Japan's leading
business associations,
the Keizai Doyukai some of
you know this organization
made headlines, I'm
gonna read you a quote.
When he declared, "That
over the course of history,
"the world's hegemon has
changed from the Netherlands"
"to Great Britain to the United States,"
"and now China is up for the challenge."
"We are at a major turning
point in world history."
"Japanese companies should
not make a hasty decision
"to withdraw from China."
It was a perfect reflection of this view
that I'm trying to communicate to you.
Now third strategic perspective
is espoused by dual hedgers.
People who want to have
their cake and eat too.
Like Yoshida, before he moved rightward
as a matter of political protection
that as I've described it,
to try to keep the military
realist at arms' length.
These folks think that neither
all in Bandwagoning with China,
nor all in dependence
upon the United States,
a US which is in relative decline,
are really in Japan's interests.
So they would like to have it both ways.
And finally, there are
those who want Japan
to keep its distance epox on both houses
keep its distances from,
its distance from both
Washington and Beijing.
They prefer autonomous defense
and would like to have Japan
use the US Japan alliance as a means
to transcend the US Japan Alliance.
Now, like the band-wagoners
the autonomous fly beneath most radars.
But if you want a taste, and
I urge you to have a taste
of the autonomy argument,
I suggest you read the
several daily tweets
that are put out by Tamogami Toshio.
You'll remember he was
the former air self-Defense
Force chief of staff who was,
who was fired in 2008 for
insisting that Japan's aggression
in northeast and southeast
Asia and the 1930s and 40s
was for a just clause.
Now, his position was not marginal.
It was certainly not what
the Japanese government
espoused was national policy.
So he was, he was fired.
He's gone, but he then
ran for governor of Tokyo
and got 16% of the vote.
That's not, it's not a majority,
it's not even close to, he
couldn't form a government,
but he got 16% of the vote.
So this is a part of the
Japanese security discourse
we can't underestimate.
The point is,
is not only that diversity in
Japanese strategic thinking,
oh, I should say he tweets,
I think I did say he tweets
all the time. Have a look.
It's very interesting stuff.
And the point is not only that diversity
in Japanese strategic
thinking is alive and well,
but also that each of these
strategic choices requires
Japan to get its relationship just right
with Washington and Beijing.
And that's, that's what
I elsewhere called the,
the goldilocks challenge to
Japan to get it just right.
And I'd be happy to
explore that further in Q&A
but let me stop here.
I've gone on too long.
Thank you very much for your attention.
(audience applause)
- [Student] Hi, thank
you Professor Samuels
for a really interesting talk.
It kind of struck me at a
certain point when you were
discussing Japan's extensions
looking for other partners
in information collecting
and perhaps defense service.
The kind of complete lack
of discussion of South Korea
and how these changes
over Taiwan have impacted
the South Korean Japanese relationship.
And I was wondering if you
could speak to that point.
- No, it's, it's great.
And, I just felt like I
had to cut off something
somewhere and you've, you nailed it.
I did not talk about the Korea.
I talked about North
Korea only in passing.
And there's been,
the relationship between
South Korea and Japan
hit a new rock bottom over
the last five to seven years.
It's never been so, I
mean, it, has been so bad,
but a new post 1965 rock bottom.
65 was the normalization
of relations and like that.
And part of it,
part of it is due to the
fact that there are actors
in both countries who
are basically the skunks
in the garden party.
And any,
any effort to have some level
of reconciliation runs into
their, these politicians,
either ideological or electoral logics
of using the other country,
the right wing in Japan
and the left wing in Korea
as foils for their own,
for their own base.
And, so there's that.
There's the fact that
that the well, you know,
obviously the history issue, right.
We call it, you're a
historian, you know about this.
The history issue has
been used in that way
in both countries, the Japanese,
by denying much of their history
and the South Koreans by
inflating in some cases some
some of the history.
But it's hard to inflate the
violence that was brought
to Korea by the Japanese.
In any event, the, there
was a, there was a lot,
there was a lot wrong
with the relationship,
but so long as the Korean electorate sent
a left-wing government
to power and maintained
a military realist government at home,
it was, it was a recipe for,
not disaster disasters, way too strong.
But it was a recipe for
significant deterioration
in the relationship.
And that's now changed with
the election of President Yoon
and the willingness of a
more moderate, Kishida,
more moderate than say
Abe was on this issue,
to try to find a solution.
I think people give the
United States credit
for, you know, knocking heads together.
We have two treaty allies out there.
They don't get along with one another.
They don't share
intelligence with one another
and they have the same
adversary in North Korea.
I don't think that the
United States deserves
the credit that it's getting.
I think, the Korean electorate
and the Japanese electorate
deserve the credit for this.
But we'll see how far it goes
'cause there are skunks in,
at that garden party.
I'm not sure if that gets, but there's,
there are many levels to the hostility
between Korean and Japan.
Some of them, again, rooted in history,
but some are quite contemporary.
Thanks. I mean, it's a great question.
It's exactly what I didn't talk about.
- [Student] I was wondering
if you could talk a little bit
more about Japan's plutonium
stocks in terms of, I mean,
this is really a break in the
nuclear taboo in many ways
that was taken without knowledge perhaps,
or the ascent of the Japanese public.
I was wondering where you see
that sort of stockpile and
desire to create a breakout
capability started coming
into place, especially since, you know,
you think things like
when the PRC tested its
first nuclear device
during the Tokyo Olympics.
I mean, that became, you know,
rather serious diplomatic crisis, right.
So, you know, where where do
you see this kind of shift
taking place over time?
- It's a, another good question.
The, we are seeing now
in the, there are two,
two papers that I know of
that have written by scholars
who have gone into the archives
and have found that there was an awareness
of what was judged then
and still is now to be
the benefits of nuclear
latency all the way back
into the 1950s and 60s.
And so the decision to go
forward with nuclear power
was a decision taken in the,
with the understanding that there would be
a collateral benefit,
which is a viable latency,
viable nuclear hedge.
So in the form of those
plutonium stockpiles.
So where are they?
A lot of them went off to
the French and the British
and so forth for a
reprocessing and so forth.
But, you know, these were
all, and some people say,
well, it's, you know,
it's in the possession of the
Japanese nuclear power firm,
the Japanese electric utilities.
But a lot of it is not.
And, you know, Japan has worked very hard
to establish itself as the paragon
of disarmament,
non-proliferation and so forth.
But it's a, it's, you know,
with apologies to those of you
in Japanese who study Japanese fine arts,
but it's a bit of a kabuki.
When 311 happened, as I
mentioned before, Morimoto saw,
who was the DPJs, minister
of defense said, no, we need,
we need this stuff as a nuclear threat.
Ishibashi, a former minister of defense
from the LDP likewise said, we need this.
We must not stop nuclear power.
And they campaign very hard for this.
Now my favorite story on this.
So the Japanese have
kept the door wide open
just to be really clear and
have defended an open door
for the reasons, for the reasons that,
with the basic reasons they
think it's a deterrent,
and it may well be, maybe.
My favorite story about this was
a story I read in a Japanese, in,
actually it was an American magazine.
I think it was a Forbes or Fortune.
It was a sort of a
high-end business magazine.
And it was an interview with an unnamed
Japanese military official
who was asked by the reporter,
how long will it take Japan
to become nuclear armed?
How long would breakout actually take?
And the reporter wrote that
his interlocutor threw up
his hands and said,
we have absolutely no plans
to do anything like that,
but if we did, it would be
186 days, exactly six months.
And so, you know, you have this,
you have this option and
that's all it is right now.
And actually fielding a nuclear
weapon comes in many forms.
And the German one we talked about still
has the United States
with its foot on the neck.
And, but there are other options as well.
The British option here,
renting nuclear weapons
is all sorts of things.
And I think depending upon how
well the United States does,
in convincing the Japanese not
to be excessively concerned
about its commitment and its
capabilities going forward,
you won't see much,
much movement toward nuclear
breakout in the near term.
But in the mid and long term,
I don't think they have
much of an option, frankly.
- [Student] Thank you for
very interesting talk.
My question is,
how do you see the new
Japanese defense posture
jiving with its demographic
transition that's taking place?
- Very good. Good question.
I'm gonna go back to, everyone understand
it's the demographic transition of Japan.
It's a great question
and it's one you have to
think about if you're study,
if you study this stuff.
I'm gonna go back to Tomogami.
It's my favorite right wing interlocutor
indirectly as it is.
I've never met the man.
He published some data yesterday,
two days ago from Densu.
It's a major Japanese
public relations company.
And it reported that 13, a little over 13%
of Japanese were willing to
fight in a war for Japan.
And then he compared that
to 80% of the Chinese
who are willing to fight
for China in a war.
Now, not only is that an
enormous gap in relative terms,
but if you factor in
the fact that Japan is,
you know, a hundred and what
is it, 120, 30 million now,
and China is, God knows, 3.0, 1.34 huge.
And so in absolute numbers,
it's an extraordinarily
large gap, demographic gap
of not just of young people,
but of people willing to fight
and die for their country.
And they have no conscription.
So I think, and they're
leaving billets unfilled
on a regular basis.
They are just not filling
their recruiting targets,
not by a long shot,
maybe a hundred thousand,
80 to a hundred thousand.
I think, I think I'm
making up those numbers,
but I don't think I'm off
by an order of magnitude.
There's an enormous
shortfall of, in recruitment.
So I think it is a serious problem.
And one way around that of course
is to use military
equipment that's not manned.
And so, and the Japanese understand that.
So they're buying more
unmanned aerial vehicles,
the more missile systems and so forth.
But that's not gonna get
them where they want to go
in a major conflict,
especially if it's a
conflict that involves
the United States and
the US wants and needs
boots on the ground,
which is what Richard Armitage
asked for the last time.
But it's a good good
question. It's a real problem.
- [Student] Yes. Thank
you Professor Samuels
for sharing your insights with us.
Prime Minister Kishida
visited Kyiv recently
when President Xi was in Moscow.
That's a major signal, obviously.
Is that something that
may divert some resources
from the Ukraine front to Eastern Russia,
or the Russians don't care at this stage?
- I'm not sure I get. What is the--
- [Student] Would Russia
see this as a reason
to divert resources from Ukraine war,
or it's not relevant?
- I don't, I don't think so.
I think what the Prime Minister was doing,
and you know, you know, color me cynical,
but he's got the G7 coming up
and he's chairing it, and it's in Japan,
and he can't really have the
authority he would otherwise
have as chair of the G7
meeting if he didn't get
to Kyiv since every one
of the other leaders did.
And so I think that's
the cynical part of me.
I don't see a shift in
the deployment of forces
that results from any of this.
In fact, I don't think
he has the authorization
and the political juice
to make that happen yet.
But I think he,
and he really was
desperate to get over there
before the G7 got started.
It was clearly all politics
on that one I think.
Domestic pol well, international politics,
but he wants the Japanese
people to understand he's a wor,
whoops, he's a world leader too.
- [Student] Thank you very
much for this talk, professor.
I think you mentioned
the number of 168 days
to achieve a nuclear weapon for Japan.
One, it's really quick process.
And I want to ask, what
will be the Chinese reaction
to any signal from Japan to
achieving a nuclear weapon?
If any Japanese step to this direction
will push China to a war in Taiwan?
- Great question. The,
first of all, I don't,
I don't believe that the 186
day is a reliable number,
but it was the number, it was
the answer that was quoted.
I think there's the, the
Japanese have a lot to do,
a lot in addition to do,
but we don't know because
so much of it is shrouded.
So, okay, let's say if
it's not six months,
it'll be, it could be a
year or a year and a half.
That's still very short.
What would be the Chinese reaction?
Predictably, very severe, I would think.
Now the question is, what does that mean?
Does it mean an attack,
a preemptive attack?
I don't think so because Japan has
a nuclear armed treaty
partner in the United States.
So I don't imagine that
that there'd be a preemptive
attack in the event that a
nuclear program is unveiled.
I'm sorry.
- [Student] To attack on Taiwan.
- Oh, an attack on Taiwan.
And you're asking about
whether the Japanese
would use nuclear weapons
in the event of a?
- [Student] China wants to.
If China will want to attack Taiwan before
the Japanese have the nuclear ability?
- Oh, I see, I see, I see.
No, I don't think so.
I don't think that, that, that would,
that would do it because I think
the Chinese have a bigger adversary
to contend with and one more
likely to get into a fight,
and that's the United States.
So I think the calculation
on whether or not, you know,
they do it before the Japanese
can become a nuclear power
is probably not high on the agenda.
Yeah, I see the question now I'm good.
- [Student] Thanks so much
for the very interesting talk.
I wanted to ask you if you
could speak a little bit
more about how Japan is going
to pay for defense budget.
I thought it was really interesting.
I hadn't heard about,
now we can count the Japan
Coast Guard as part of
the defense budget and that
gets us part of the way there.
I'm wondering about
what your thoughts about
how they get the rest of the way there,
but also I'm wondering how
much you see the success
of pledges like this or the NSS
more generally as tied
to the fate of Kishida.
So Kishida doesn't seem
like particularly popular.
The policies might be popular,
but he's not necessarily that popular
with the public right now.
Do you see these policies
as popular enough
within the public and the
LDP that even if Kishida
were to say, you know,
not last long enough
to implement them,
they'll probably go on without him, or,
I'm just curious how
much you see it as tied
to Kishida's own political future?
- Yeah, and I think actually Kishida
has been bold on this one in a way that
I wouldn't have expected
in the sense that he's
been in favor of tax increase.
Whereas others have said, no, no, no,
let's do, let's sell bonds.
We'll make the children and grandchildren
and foreigners pay for this, I think.
And, but he went for the tax increase,
but he's not got the
support that he needs.
He's not got the support
he needs for that.
So how do you get there?
Well, it's not just the
Coast Guard, remember,
it's also any government
funding for dual use
or dual use technologies.
And that, you know, that's a big tent.
That's a huge tent
'cause almost everything
is a dual use technology
according to it's proponents.
You know, it's the people
who are looking for the funding, right.
So it's duel use.
And I, you know, it would be interesting
to actually do some back of the envelope,
at least back of the envelope calculations
on how far that gets them.
But it's clearly not far enough
because they're still
talking about tax and bonds.
And there may be some, perhaps some
agreement reached some kind of a,
a negotiated settlement reach
between the advocates for each.
But I sort of doubt it that
the LDP has had nothing.
But as you know, Charlie,
the LDP has had nothing but trouble.
Every time it raises taxes,
it gets hammered by voters, hammered.
And so it's not only they
don't wanna fight and die
for their country, they
don't wanna pay taxes either.
They already do pay
tax, pay a lot of taxes.
They don't wanna pay more taxes.
So I think he's in a bind.
But I got the impression that,
that his popularity has improved
in the last couple three weeks.
And I think getting over to Kyiv
back to that question from
the gentleman up here.
Getting to Kyiv and
demonstrating leadership
of this sort will further
reinforce and maybe even lead to
an early solution of
diet and the reelection.
So that's my guess is the
calculation there. Yeah.
- [Student] Am I able to? Can I ask?
- So--
- Oh there you are.
- [Student] Thank you very
much for a wonderful talk.
And, I was trying to
think of a brave question,
but I'm a comparative.
I'm gonna ask about voters,
and this is actually a
perfect follow up I think
to Charlie's question
because I was also interested
in the payment for these new programs
or for the expansion
of the defense budget.
And I know the IR scholars are interested
in what sinks battleships,
and we are interested
in what sinks the LDP.
And so I'm curious, right,
if the current trend among
Japanese leaders is realist,
can we construe public opinion?
Can we construe the
voters as well as realists
or merely realists accommodating for now?
And, that is to say,
when push comes to shove,
is everybody a realist until
they come for your pension?
- It's like the,
everyone's a liberal until
they get mugged, right, right.
Yeah. No.
Okay. I don't know the
answer to that except to say,
except to report to you something
you already know, Colin,
which is that the, I keep doing that.
That the Japanese voters
now report support.
They're not just accommodating to Abe,
they're actually supporting
military realist programs and postures.
That they, it seems to me real,
a real shift that the
center of gravity has moved
in Japanese public opinion
and that it's a real thing.
And, but you know, it's also,
it's also true in the United States
that everybody is, you know,
let's go fight this war.
We do this all the time
until it's your children
or your neighbor's children,
and then you're not so
enthusiastic anymore, right.
So, or shouldn't be anyway.
So I think that, I think it's,
I think it's a real change,
I guess is the bottom line.
It's substantive, it's
real, it's calculable and
I think sustainable.
China, China's just been, as
I said, overplayed its hand.
China had, could have achieved
so much more by not being
as provocative as it's been in the region.
And, now during the Abe administration,
Abe goes to Beijing and
he talks to Xi Jinping
and they work out, a whole
list of economic agreements
is October now of 2018, I think, right.
And they work out a
whole set of agreements.
And it looked like, you know,
that Abe had moved to the
center from the right,
as it turned out, nothing ever took place,
nothing ever happened.
It was all for show.
And so the real,
the reality is everyone has
moved to the right in Japan.
- [Student] Thank you so
much for your wonderful talk.
So my question is on.
So you mentioned how the
overall business sector of Japan
right now favors increasing
betrayed interactions with China.
And I want to know how to
what extent it represents
the sentiment, the concept,
the perception of the general public,
the small business owners,
especially tourism on tourism,
or it represents the
wilderness of the elite class,
the big companies.
And to what extent can this
business oriented sentiment
impact the policy making
of the Japanese government?
- Yeah. I mean I think
business is more divided.
I mean, what I was trying to
get at was that there is a part
of business like the
Keizai Doyukai spokesperson
who sees China as the future and so forth.
But I think business is
quite divided on China.
There are those who are dependent
upon imports from China,
like rare earth metals, for example,
who were denied access to
them and then had to hustle
to find alternative sourcing and so forth,
due to political, political,
bilateral political disputes, right.
So you have, you have, in a sense,
the Japanese business
community is split between
those who built big factories in China
and want them to succeed.
It's an enormous capital investments.
And those who are trying to extract
certain raw materials.
The people who are at the
top of the value added chain
will not necessarily have
the same set of interests
vis-a-vis trade with China
as the bottom of the value added chain.
I only offered the example
I offered to illustrate one
particular corner of
the security discourse.
I don't think it represented
all of Japanese business.
It represented those who really,
who really see it as China as the future,
but that's not everyone.
- [Student] Thank you
so much for the talk.
So I have a question about
the underlying courses of the,
of the change of public opinion
about the military policies.
'Cause it seems at least
to me that the reason for,
the reason for the change is not limited
to how the Japanese like
right-wing partition emphasize
the, like China threat discourse,
but also it can be attributed to
the loss of public resonance
of one's board pacifist movement.
So I would like to ask for what reason
the Japanese pacific
activists came to lose
the public resonance
that they wants to have?
- Well, I think that,
as I said in my remarks,
there were three reasons.
One was that for many Japanese citizens,
they recognized that China was
a security threat to Japan.
That they came to see it
as Abe was painting it.
And the Abe group,
the military realist that I described.
And so they understood that.
That's kind of a highfalutin view
because not everybody in, you know,
in the Japanese public sees things
in these kinds of strategic terms.
But they're are the
three strategic reasons.
One is that North Korea,
I mean it's throwing
hardware over the archipelago
and nuclear missiles.
And he's been doing it
for 10, 12 years now.
And, it's very provocative.
And so they see that as a threat.
So North Korea is a threat.
They see China as a threat.
And you know, there's a lot of,
of fuss over the strategic importance
of a very unstrategic bit of land,
which is the Senkaku.
I mean, Senkaku islands are
inside the first island chain.
If the Chinese get the Senkaku islands,
they still can't get out
of the first island chain.
If they get Taiwan, you
know all bets are off,
then they're out into the Philippines Sea.
But so it's the threat
from China as they see it,
the threat from North
Korea as they see it.
And as I say, the demonstrable
threat of the Americans
not caring much.
President Trump made it very
clear, you know, within two,
within a week after his inauguration,
he bailed out on the TPP, the
Trans-Pacific Partnership.
And what did we get?
This week the British joined
the Trans-Pacific Partnership.
They left BREXIT, and they
left, you know, the EU
and they, joined the
trans, much bigger market.
And the Americans are left out in the cold
to these bilateral,
bilateral FTAs and so forth.
So anyway, the point is the Americans
in the Trump administration there was
the dropping of the TPP,
which, you know, it you know,
for domestic political reasons,
which we can talk about.
Number one, the demands
that host nation support
be double tripled,
you know, and really telling the Japanese
that they're only good for, you know,
that we're only there to be
mercenaries and we'll fight
for you, but you gotta
pay us a lot more money.
He just didn't understand the
strategic issues, didn't care.
And he was doing that.
And of course, after the,
after his first visit to Korea,
he was very, North Korea visit with,
I should say Kim Jong-un.
I guess in Singapore that summer.
He made it very clear
that the United States
didn't care about medium
range nuclear weapons.
They cared about intercontinental
ballistic missiles.
And so the result was he's,
and he said it out loud,
well, of course, you
know, if you're Japanese,
you know, you care about
both or you should.
And you feel quite abandoned
by the United States
when you get a president
of the United States
saying such things.
So there's, those are the
three strategic reasons,
and I think they just have,
have been fed a steady diet
of news about the Senkaku.
I mean, you know, there's poor
goats on the Senkaku island,
there's a lot of goats
there, but that's about,
that's about it.
Anyway, they're fed a steady
diet about imminent aggression.
And you know, on some of it sticks.
Some of it as we've seen in
the United States, you know,
there's some of the most
outrageous outlandish things stick
and you gotta deal with
it politically at home.
- [Student] Thank you
for the interesting talk.
So I have a question.
I've wonder, I'm curious to
know the role of electoral poli,
electoral competition in
determining foreign policy in Japan.
So maybe I missed up in the talk,
but are there any factions in
LDP and do different parties
have different stance on this,
on China threat and non-foreign
policy in general? Yeah.
- Yeah. No. Yes, the
answer is yes and yes.
The LDP, since its in,
since its in initiation in the 1950s,
has been split between a
nationalist wing in the book,
I call them the Revisionist
wing, but it's a national,
they wanted to revise the constitution,
but it's really should have,
I should have called it
the nationalist wing.
Which was Kishi Nobusuke,
Abe's grandfather
and Natasone Yaskuro.
And those guys.
And the pragmatists under Yoshida Shigeru
and his follower.
And you know, there was
the pragmatists were
they were pragmatic,
and they didn't do things to inflame
the bilateral relationships
in foreign policy
in the way that the nationalists would.
And in fact, it's curious because
from American perspective,
it seemed that there's no,
there was no better friend
of the United States
than Kishi Nobusuke,
which is very, very ironic
since he was a, you know,
an unindicted war criminal
spent time in Sugamo prison.
He was Abe's grandfather.
And but you know, he was anti-communist.
That was good enough for
us during the Cold War.
So there are those two big groups.
Now there are factions which
are not all policy defined.
There's leadership.
And so for example, you
get someone like Aso,
former Prime Minister
and former vice prime
deputy, prime minister and so forth.
He's got all sorts of
people in his faction.
They're not all military realists.
And, those factions matter.
And we saw how much they
mattered when Abbe ordered
his faction or signaled to his faction
that it should not support Kishida.
And he had to cobble together
support from the rest of
the factions to get become
president of the party
and then prime minister.
So these things do matter.
And the Kishida folks, as I
described them in my remarks,
are these dual hedgers who
would like to have it both ways.
They think that they can.
And so Kishida comes out
of that Yoshida school
and is identified with a
much more moderate approach
to China historic over the last say,
well, he was foreign minister, you know.
So while he was foreign minister,
he was a much more deliberate,
pragmatic approach,
which didn't, I don't think transform,
it didn't transform Chinese behavior.
And as I say, I think to the Chinese,
I said it several times already,
I won't repeat it, but
they miscalculate it.
- [Speaker] Please join with
me in thanking Professor Samuel
for his grim but enlightening talk.
- Thank you.
(audience applause)
Thank you.
(soft music)